HER TO BE A PART OF THIS
COLLABORATION.
IT MAY END UP BEING THE END OF
SUMMER JAM WE ALL NEED AS A
CONFIDENCE BOOST.
>> SHE CANCELED HER INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNT BUT IS POSTING THINGS ON
YOUTUBE, INCLUDING AN AUDIO CLIP
WHERE SHE ADDRESSES HER
CONSERVATORSHIP.
LET'S LISTEN TO THIS.
>> IF YOU ARE A WEIRD, INT VERT,
ODDBALL LIKE ME WHO FEELS ALONE
A LOT OF THE TIME AND YOU NEEDED
TO HEAR A STORY LIKE THIS TODAY
SO YOU DON'T FEEL ALONE, KNOW
THIS, MY LIFE HAS BEEN FAR FROM
EASY AND YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT
BRITNEY IS CONTINUING TO BE
CANDID ABOUT WHAT SHE WENT
THROUGH DURING THAT 13-YEAR
COURT ORDERED CONSERVATORSHIP.
THIS IS A TIME WHERE BRITNEY
FEELS LIKE SHE CAN TAKE THAT
TAPE OFF OF HER MOUTH AND TALK
STRAIGHT FROM HER HEART TO HER
FANS AND TO EVERYBODY ELSE TO
REALLY REVEAL WHAT'S BEEN
TROUBLING HER.
SHE TALKS ABOUT IN THAT AUDIO
CLIP BEING THROWN AWAY, FEELING
LIKE HER FAMILY HAD ABANDONED
HERE, FEELING LIKE SHE WAS OUT
THERE ON HER OWN.
THANKING THE PEOPLE OF THE FREE
BRITNEY MOVEMENT WHICH WAS THE
MAJORITY OF FANS JUST OUT THERE
SAYING THAT WE KNOW SOMETHING IS
GOING ON, THAT THEY ARE NOT
TELLING US ABOUT.
AND NOW THAT SHE HAS THE POWER
TO JUST SPEAK HER MIND FREELY,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT SHE'S DOING.
I THINK THAT THE NEW SONG IS
HELPING HER WITH HER CONFIDENCE,
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT THIS IS A
TIME WHERE SHE FEELS LIKE SHE'S
REALLY VULNERABLE, TOO.
>> IT'S SAD LISTENING TO HER
TALK ABOUT WHAT SHE'S BEEN
THROUGH, BUT IT ALSO SOUNDS LIKE
THE OLD BRITNEY THAT I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T FEEL THAT
TH